New York Times reporter Amy chose expend
maybe more time covering Hillary Clinton
than any living person through to
presidential campaigns any decade she
has a new book out it's called chasing
Hillary ten years two campaigns one in
tech glass ceiling jozek describes a lot
about Hillary her profane tirades
against Trump
she knows with wonder how many men
accused a sex harassment surrounded
Clinton she also concedes that she was
charmed by Hillary a lot of the time
Amy chosen for the New York Times joins
us tonight me thanks for coming on so
you've taken some grief for this book
from the right that says you know you
can see it in the book that you had
affinity for Hillary sure politics I
just want to say at the outset I like
the fact that you were honest about it
unlike a lot of reporters whose you sort
of have to guess I think you're really
direct and I appreciate it but given
that the Hillary people are always
sniping about you and complaining about
you like you're the problem why it seems
to say a lot about them exactly
apparently this is the book that the
Clintons don't want you to read and as
you point out it is partly sympathetic
to her and so I anticipated the blowback
I mean part of what I get in to at the
book is that there's no gray area for
Hillary Clinton you're either completely
devoted to her or you're or you're an
enemy and you know a lot of the times my
coverage was was in-between and
sometimes I wrote some tough stories I
mean I was the beat reporter covering
this campaign day in and day out and so
you know there wasn't a lot of gray area
either the enemy or you were you know
completely devoted but I mean how sort
of out of it you have to be and I know
the Clinton people feel this way to
think that like the New York Times is to
right-wing to cover Hillary Clinton I've
heard them they've said that to me so I
know they actually feel that way planted
are they on well they're on planet
Hillary and I which I've written about
extensively and one of the themes in the
book that I think your viewers will find
surprising is this decades-long battle
between the New York Times and the
Clinton campaign it was something I was
naive about when I was put on the beat
in 2013 I hadn't anticipated that her
aides would essentially blame me for the
white water scandal which Tucker
happened when I was 12 but there's all
this which of course the New York Times
broke there is all this bad blood that
has been passed on between the Clintons
and the New York Times from generation
to generation of which I was a recipient
of
put on her 2016 campaign I mean I think
it would surprise a lot of people that
that animosity exists
so tell C's mad at you and criticizing
you on Twitter
yes Chelsea sent about 30 tweets in the
past few days criticizing some of my
reporting let me ask you a question so
you said it in the book and I think I
knew this that the overwhelming majority
beat reporters covering Hillary over
women mm-hmm Hillary was running a
campaign based essentially on the fact
that she was a woman if Warren hatch was
running for president and like 15 out of
17 reporters covering him were faithful
Mormons you would say maybe that's not
you know that's kind of stack on the
deck a little bit do you see a problem
with with that arrangement that's
interesting because one of the things in
the book that I point out is like
Hillary actually like the guys you know
like you're your very own Edie Henry
would grill her about her emails and
then she kind of liked it you know she
liked the banter with him and she was
she was sort of flirty with some of the
guys and so I don't think that there was
a particularly love fest because women
were covering her if anything I think
there was the perception that women
might be tougher on her to kind of prove
you know the counter to your point to
prove that we weren't in the tank and
she's tough right is she the first
self-described feminist you've ever met
who's harder on women than she is on men
I cannot answer that question I give the
New York Times thank you for coming on I
appreciate thanks for having me great to
talk to you